all right here we go um welcome
um i don't know who's i don't know who
greets who hosts or anything i had some
thoughts so i'm gonna jump right in
uh this is this is i think in some ways
this is a little bit of consolation for
the fact that we can't meet
this september in thunder bay yeah
and you know my um my hats off to
urban abbey and their desire to put this
together
and i really hope that next year we'll
have the ability
to do this right and i hope that nothing
i hope that what we do today uh adds to
the anticipation
and um actually in my experience with
conversations the more
we talk together the better our
conversations will get
because we know each other better yeah
thank you for saying that paul and thank
you for uh
welcoming us here uh i hope i can get a
copy of this files because i want to
upload it on my channel as well
and uh so i will i will send it out
today right after we're done
great and jonathan as always it's great
to see you as well
paul i hope that things have stabilized
for you a bit
um you're in my thoughts well thank you
no it's been you know with covid and
that impact on the church and
so i've just been trying to launch some
new initiatives
and you know i have this day job which
people often don't recognize
but uh it's it's it's a real day job and
so
when when things get a little crazy
things get a little crazy
so youtube comes second oh i didn't i'd
haven't i haven't been following i guess
the situation are you strong is you're
having some issues at the church with
with
yeah you know it's covered craziness
well it
i think a lot of it is um you know
california is locked down who knows for
how long
and so i think some of the older members
of the church
are who live at a distance um especially
widows
i mean their children mom you shouldn't
drive that far to that church and
so how what will emerge after covid is
difficult to know
so i've been i announced two new
efforts which really aren't any
different from what really aren't a lot
different from what i've been doing
one is to continue to help
the church connect better online as
church but then also
more my youtube's channel which is at
which i call
estuary which is much more a
a a a place where it's similar to the
what we've been doing with our jordan
peterson meetup
it's just a place for outside the walls
of the church i use your
your icon of everything often jonathan
in this because it's
it's estuary sort of outside the wall a
church needs a place
for its it's its flow to go and
um so that's that's what i've been doing
and uh
but it's it's going fine and i'm doing
i'm doing well it's exciting
but uh yeah we'll see what we'll see
what happens
okay i thought we might begin by
i'd like to hear from both of you
we've we've sort of been cast together
what
we're a strange trio
and i'd like to i'd like to hear from
both of you where things are
at with you and why why this
conversation
now okay well i'll go first
um i really like uh
what you sent in the email paul i
thought that was excellent i was
proposing some
general topics uh you know i'm really
interested in
the the emerging discussion about the
relationship between symbolism and the
cultivation of wisdom
um and that weaves through both of your
work
in uh pretty uh uh important ways
uh but i don't know if that's ever been
explicit a topic of discussion
but then you did something i thought was
very good paul
you you pointed out that there's this
emerging realization uh which i
completely agree with and i'm i think
i'm exemplifying
the thing you're pointing to uh that you
know sense making meaning making wisdom
cultivation
is not it's insufficient to just have a
personal philosophy
on individual practice one needs
community and ultimately
that community needs culture and
um so i see you guys having
uh traditions uh that are worthy of
entering into dialogue with about that
um i'm
i'm engaged in that process right now
and that was motivated by a criticism
that jonathan made
that i took to heart uh and i because i
i
i love both of you guys and i care about
what you have to say and i take it
seriously
and so jonathan made the point about you
know well john does all these sort of
individual i think you called the
mystical practices
um but there isn't that and i i've
so i've launched this whole project of
dialectic and via logos and paul you're
contributing
uh to uh the to that anthology
um and and then also building community
doing that building the sangha the
morning
community around the meditation and
contemplation now we're going through
the western wisdom traditions
epicureanism stoicism neoplatonism
and then the discord server and then uh
meeting with uh like was at the moving
movement summit and all these emerging
communities of practices i mean
it was just an impressive summit all
these emerging communities and practices
and you know how they're all responding
to the meeting crisis and there's this
desire to network together
um and build a culture and i've sort of
been building this
sort of somewhat a little bit
tongue-in-cheek but uh you know this
slogan akira the dawn did
you know steal the culture he did a
meeting wave around it and that whole
idea so i want to talk to you guys
about that because i think uh well
jonathan made the criticism i respond to
it and then paul you've made
also a criticism that i've taken to
heart the scalability
issue um uh and then the issue about
you know um that there's value to
and and you use this term so it's not
pejorative the slowness of tradition
that there's a value to that and so i
take that
all of those points seriously and then
like i said i think that is a meshed up
with this ongoing discussion that's
emerging um it's actually
a predict pretty significant discussion
on my discord server community
about jonathan about the relationship of
the symbolic way
uh you know the symbolic mode of
cognition and is that a way of knowing
um is it um is it um
more properly understood as something
that affords understanding and wisdom
so that's also something that people are
wanting to bring in discussion
in connection with the project of
community building
and i take it that that's not a
coincidence so that's what i'm
interested in
and that's what i want to uh
that's what i would like to bring into
discussion right now
yeah i think i mean i think that the
continuation of this
moment in terms of
recognizing the meaning crisis and you
know the fact that it's
accelerating to a certain extent in
terms of
the this year i mean we kind of i if you
would have asked me when i thought it
would be
accelerate i would have known it was
2020 because i i mentioned it before
just because of the election because of
what happened in 2016
similar things happen and that's what
launched this
thing like in 2016 that's when jordan
appeared on the
on the horizon and it was in
relationship to
what was going on the these crazy
protests were happening
not as bad as now but it was similar in
terms of
a kind of accentuation of the of this
this kind of meaning crisis and so it's
not surprising that right now it's
ramping up again
and it's ramping up even more and
there's
the kovit has also added a whole layer
which brings it into our body that we
talked about
um john and i in our last discussion
and i've had a lot of people really
appreciate our last discussion by the
way a lot of people really
really yeah i i did too thank you for
that jonathan
and so i think that i think that it
really is
a moment where we need to continue to
examine what's happening and try to
propose the little
solutions we can and propose ways of
being
that can avoid the polarization that is
kind of manifesting itself
and so in that sense that's what i see
as um
as the the continuation of this
discussion and i think
but also i think of course the whole
idea
to me the the central question and the
question i think which
most interests me and mostly i think
needs to be worked out and played out is
the question of
emergence the relationship between
emergence or the the relationship
between the bottom
up and the top down yeah in terms of in
terms of uh
understanding how reality works itself
out that to me is the
biggest question in always trying to to
work through ways to talk about it to
think about it more and to make it more
to make it clearer um and so that's
really what
what fascinates me with this discussion
and also
the access that john you give us to
kagsai and to other elements which
weren't part of our like part of my
vocabulary at least and weren't part of
my horizon
and so it's actually adding a lot of
breath to let's say breadth to the the
to my thinking
and i find like i think i mentioned this
every time i talk to you but i always
find myself
you know i talk to this um to this group
of uh
union psychologists at assisi foundation
they invited me to do a conference and
it just i found myself using your terms
because
in in that context this is these are the
right terms to use you know
if i use just christian terms in that
context
some of them won't even understand what
i'm talking about but if i talk about
uh combinatorial explosion then they're
like
they then they kind of understand where
i'm going in terms of
the problem of emergence one of the
great
joys of my work of my
work has been exactly what you said
that people are finding the
the conceptual vocabulary and the
theoretical grammar affording
to them uh that that is that that brings
me a lot of
uh happiness and knowing that i've been
able to help people that way
and i think it's valuable that even if
people
you know disagree with me on some
central points and both of you do
i'm in different ways you nevertheless
can take my work up in a way
that is affording of the good work that
you guys are doing so that that pleases
me
quite deeply so thank you for sharing
that and paul i was excited to see
some crossover between our our kind of
crews or whatever like
one of the people who's really involved
in the symbolic world discussion i think
hosted a
a an event on your discord server and so
i wasn't massively wasn't able to
attend but i was just happy to see that
happening yeah yeah
well i i think one of the things that
all of our work and i'm
perhaps as the protestant coming late to
the party is the recognition
of the the continued breakdown
of of them of the modern
liberal consensus as the unifying
sense making something which had a
particular
had a particular take on science and and
and what you know how what we talk about
as science in our culture
and i i see that as
you know it's been interesting because
both of you have
have shown me from different ways again
i think jonathan you're right it's kind
of the emergence and the and the
emanation
have shown me from different ways how
the the sense making consensus
is breaking down and of course as i
think we saw
in in the you know with the protestant
reformation was
a breakdown of of an institutional
authority and a sense-making consensus
which led to
the enlightenment and all of this this
new paradigm
now as i think we see the the the
continued recession of the new paradigm
which which is ironically
also fueled by science because you know
a lot of what i've learned from
from from you john and from having
watched jordan peterson
kind of sparked it is that there are
scientific reasons for the breakdown of
the old paradigm
and jonathan pajot coming along and
saying quite clearly
i don't think anyone would understand my
channel if the recession
hadn't in a sense um exposed so much
beach and so now we're beginning to see
some very
old things that were beneath the surface
and so
and that then brings us into the
question
because communities require and i've
been listening to
uh stephen stephen smith who wrote a
very interesting book
uh pagans and christians in the city
that look
at basically the breakdown of of
of the sense making of lake lay
antiquity
and the coming on of christianity in
that period and i think we're we're in
again one of those moments but each
each community that has stakes just you
know with the breakdown of
christendom the you know christians of
course
resisted resisted resisted but while
you're resisting you're also
accommodating
and that then leads to the next paradigm
so it's very
interesting to watch both of you because
in some ways you're both seeing the
breakdown
and seeking new communities and a new
consensus
but jonathan sort of from the ancient
and and john from the scientific modern
it's been fascinating to to have both
watched both of you
in this process well i hope jonathan
feels that
um as a scientist i'm also deeply
respectful and informed by the ancient
i mean uh so the neoplatonic and
socratic traditions
as well as the as well as the christian
and buddhist
and taoist traditions um have have deep
influence on me
but i like the way you position things
paul i i
i think it's a fair um i think what's
interesting
because i think this this might be one
of those
issues that that is scalable in the way
you've been talking about
paul because i see at the sort of the
highest levels
of both theology and metaphysics
you know even within an academic arena
um
i see people really wrestling with these
issues now
of emergence and emanation like adam
like at a high metaphysical level um and
you can even see it in the science
you know quantum the quantum theory is
very much about how things emerge upward
and then relativity theory is very much
about how the cosmological
emanates down and curves and shapes
things so this this
grammar of emergence and emanation is
it's pervasive in
like a lot of the work that's happening
um you know
you know in even formal ontology in
science
but i think you're right uh when you say
because you
wrote it in your email like one of the
burning issues now is what's the
relationship
between uh these emerging communities
these emerging rituals these emerging
psycho technologies too much
is my term and the established
traditions um it's interesting that
christianity now finds itself on the
other side of that dynamic
like so i i i take the analogy uh to
late antiquity to be a good one
where christianity is the the new the
new kid on the block
um and facing uh the
at times trenchant conservatism of pagan
of paganism
um and then the dialogue that went there
and that but now christianity is on the
other side it seems to me at least
historically
and so i'm wondering like we've got to
pay attention to that analogy
but we've got to get the analogy the
right way too and so it's a tricky
question to ask
like and so i mean i've been trying to
you know because of what you guys both
said
um again i take what you say seriously
you know providing the grammar
and and the and the vocabulary is really
important and empowering that's why i've
been doing a lot of work on this notion
of the practice of dialectic right
and how it engenders the logos as a way
of
moving us out of oppositional uh into
opponent processing discourse
in which emergence is a sought-after
feature
of the dialogue right and then
but also and you know jonathan i've been
having discussions with jp about this jp
morso
can we situate that practice into
a medic into a metaphysical dialectic
and again i think there is precedent
both within
uh neoplatonism the pagan tradition but
also clearly
uh you know maximus right within
the the within the christian tradition
at least the eastern
orthodox christian tradition for a
dialectical metaphysics
and so and like i said it seems that
i'm trying to find that as a potential
place where practice
and metaphysics can properly start to
resonate with each other
that's the project i've been engaging in
to try and address this issue but
how can we can get the emergence of the
emanation
i'm saying that the the like the as you
said christianity is
the tradition emanates it emanates the
constraints of possibility
right right the paradigm is emanated
into the culture if you'll allow me that
and so that's that's what i've been
trying to do
uh to various degrees of failure and
success about trying to
recapture the ancient socratic and
neoplatonic
uh practices of dialectic and then put
them into discourse with all these
emerging discourse modalities
now you guys both of you i think have
met guy send stock
like you know the circling modalities
and peter lindberg and the anti-debate
modalities
uh and the insight diet like the number
of these even in the anthologies
right the number of these things is
growing and
and i think there's good reason for that
i think there's a deep
emerging understanding that we need to
commune and i use that word specifically
we need to learn how to commune with
each other together
again in a powerful way if we're going
to get the kind of
right relationship between emanation and
emergence at least that's what that's
that's
what i'm proposing i'm proposing to the
two of you i want to hear what you think
about that and
how you want to respond to that um
well i mean i think that
my the i feel like right now i feel like
we're just going to go over the same
elements of our discussion that we
always go over which is which is fine
because we haven't worked through them
um to me that the
i think the the element which i find
that is
that will the element that
i think will prevent this from
completely
consolidating is the is the narrative is
the lack of narrative
and i know that that you talk about a
post-narrative possibility
um the difficulty is that there is a
narrative that is
we're going through it right now right
all the protests in the us
are a narrative that is where we're
we're burning
in the narrative right it's it's it's
running through
our society and there's competing
narratives and there's a there's a
there's a fight between the narrative
one of the reasons why there's a fight
is that the narrative
has come down to the strictly political
level of narrative right and so let's
say
christians what christians had and what
i think they still
do have is they have an eschatological
narrative
that is they have a narrative which is
understood
as this playing out of history at a
grand grand scale or part of a
story and of course the early christians
thought like it was imminent
and the late christians think that it's
imminent it's also actually part of the
narrative to think that it's imminent
because it
ends up being a driving force towards
behavior like a driving force towards
the manner in which we engage with
what's here that it's on the one hand
pressing on the other hand
uh temporary um and we're looking
towards
a let's say a goal of manifesting that
which is beyond history
but we're doing it within history um and
so there
so what i think that's the i think that
if we don't recapture a narrative
then we're going to be a slave of
narrative or we're going to be
we're going to be eaten up by the
narrative that brought about
uh that brought about the world wars in
20th century and that
are playing out in similar fashion today
and that
the narrative is it's it's exactly the
problem
that we're talking about that is the two
sides
are a they're the same sides they're the
same size as
the question because there's one side
which is a
bottom up side which is which which
looks
in its diseased way it looks like
communism
looks like revolution looks like uh
let's say
kind of uh equalizing of everything
and then there's another side which is a
top-down
version of the the the disease which is
a
clamp down enforced hierarchy enforced
identity enforced
uh structures enforced state mass state
mass control
all of the and so the two narratives are
are
an image of the very problem of the
meaning crisis
which is how to co how to join together
the bottom up and the top down in a
communal manner rather than
a a battle between two sides of a story
um and so that's why i think that i
think that
although i really appreciate the
practices and i think that i'll
i think that the direction people are
going and the questions they're asking
they're all the right questions and
they're they're the kind of people that
i want to talk to let's say it that way
because i feel like
they're in the right mindset in
everything but we also
can't ignore that
the world is on a collision course again
and
and that it's very difficult to to to we
can't just like i don't know
i'm not saying to i'm not i'm not even a
very political person i'm not involved
politically but i also
realize that it's a narrative fight that
we're seeing
i i wonder if for the sake of our
listeners because i remember the talk
you two had before
last um we can get pretty esoteric here
i wonder if you might um flesh out a
little bit
what you mean by eminence what you mean
by
emergence because you're right jonathan
um and as watching both of your
materials
um you know and thinking about this it's
in some ways the
the structure of our conversation has
developed
and so um on my last video i
uh strawn has strawn is is kind of my
always watching john and uh always
sending me clips
did you get did you see this one did you
see this one so i wonder if for the sake
of our audience you could
sketch out a little bit what you mean by
emergence
what we mean by eminence and then where
is
where is the where is the conflict or at
least not
the conflict but where where is the
where where is the the
fold in this conversation with respect
to narrative
because i think with with the non-theism
and theism
with the the the non-um
a system which is not necessarily um
bound to tell us versus narrative
which is energized by telos yeah i
wonder if you guys could
you know flesh that out a little bit for
the audience
lest we lose them right away yeah
yeah so thank you paul let's yeah let's
do that let's keep our audience with us
because we
we want as many companions on the way as
possible um
so um i'll try from uh and and i'll
i i won't claim to be exhausted because
jonathan will have a take on this
i'll speak from sort of a cog size
scientific perspective about how these
terms are being used
and then my particular take on them and
then i'll say something about
um narrative that maybe will be a bit of
moving towards
uh uh closing the gap between us in this
a bit
but because of a discussion with strong
actually so um
on the discord server you might be
alluding to that so um
so emergence is you know an issue in
pakistan it's one of the ways
in which it where it came to the fore
initially and jonathan will be
and paul you're probably the interest in
this too is around of course the
discussion of consciousness
um i don't want to get into a debate
about consciousness here i'm just using
this
this is a historical point i'm making
i'm not making a substantial point right
now
i'm doing that elsewhere okay but here
for us and the idea was
well uh because many people have
rejected
um uh dualism the sort of cartesian
position of mind
and many people had come to reject a
reductive physicalism that it's sort of
just the sort of the
the properties of matter as given by
physics that
you could reduce consciousness to that
many people started talking about the
fact
first that there's emergence the idea
and the standard
analogy and it's strong as an analogy
but also very weak as an analogy
is i have hydrogen it's a gas
i have oxygen it's a gas right
but when they interact together you get
water
and water has emerging has emergent
properties it has properties that
neither hydrogen
nor oxygen has it's wet it's a liquid
it's consumable
it's nutritious to us in a way that you
know
oxygen but hydrogen isn't etc etc or the
way
sodium and chloride are both poisons but
when you put them together you get salt
which is a nutritious
right so you get the idea of from from
the parts
you get a hole of some kind that has new
properties
new ways of interacting with the world
that are not
found in the parts that's emergence and
then people started to realize
that that just is that's not just a case
about consciousness
it's a case about uh life it's also a
case about knowledge this is an argument
that i make uh that you know it can't
all be
the the only we can't say that the only
thing that's real is the bottom level
because if that's if that's the only
thing that's real
then the dial that i'm using to read my
equipment to tell me about the quantum
particles isn't real and that means the
knowledge isn't real
and i take it as this that if if
if i'm claiming x is real then i'm
required to complain
that my knowledge of x is real and
therefore the gauge is real
and the information is real so i've been
arguing that emergence is a much more
comprehensive
that's why i keep saying i'm not a
reductive physicalist right i'm not a
reductive physical
so emergence is this
but as that's been happening
people have been noticing yes but
we have to talk this emergence isn't
this word gets used periodically isn't
willy-nilly
it doesn't just you know it there are
constraints on it so while there are
while there are enabling constraints
like hydrogen and oxygen coming together
to make water there's also the idea but
there must be
there must be principles
that constrain the patterns
of emergence that we reliably
see because this emergence
continues to be intelligibly like it
it continues to produce intelligible
patterns for us
and so more and more people talk about
well there must be sets of what are
called selective constraints
that are sort of really existing
and i notice i i've also argued we have
to change the meaning of possibility
real possibilities real constraints on
that shape what's probable for us so
that of
all of the ways things could emerge this
kind
of water emerges out of hydrogen and
oxygen etc right
um and so and like i said you can see
this riven through
the metaphysics of physics the project
of trying to get quantum which is about
bottom-up emergence
and relativity which is about top-down
emanation because what is relativity
it's not an event
right relativity isn't an event it's a
consent
it's a set of constraints on what is
possible
in the universe right so even science
is therefore caught in having to
acknowledge
both emergence and emanation and
facing tremendous conceptual difficulty
right physics has been uh this gets me
into trouble every time i say this
physics has been sort of more abundant
theoretically for a long time
if you want a place where theory is
really caught in science go to biology
physics well they keep generating
theories yeah they keep generating
theories that
fall apart to try and bring these two
together
now not everybody will come to what i'm
going to say but
i'm not alone in saying that you know
i suspect there's some deep conceptual
difficulty that is preventing
the reconciliation of those two and i
think something more in a union sense
something more of a paradigmatic shift
has to be brought in
uh to res to resolve that in physics and
then i think
that has to be consistent and coherent
with all these other places
where the where the emergence and the
emanation in biology
in cognitive science about consciousness
it there's a grand
multi-nested reconciliation between
emergence and emanation that is needed
now i take jonathan's point because i
always take your point seriously about
narrative
and strawn proposed to me that the the
practices of dialectic
are a new con are narrative but in a new
kind
and here's and i had a really
interesting discussion uh with
james carse the guy who wrote the
religious case against belief
on the stoa because he wrote the book
finite and infinite games
and he distinguishes between a finite
game that has played to completion
and an infinite game that is played for
continuance
um and he said that we have to
and what trump proposed to me said is
that
there is a kind of narrative that's
in conversation but it's not
the narrative of a finite game and then
i took this up with james
it's the narrative of the infinite game
it's where the point of the narrative is
constantly to try and change
um the rules by which you're playing out
the narrative so the conversation
right is supposed to be open-ended in an
important fashion
and so i'm
i'm yeah again i don't know if i i take
very seriously the post-modern critique
of there's no meta-narrative
but i am coming to think that there is
something at least
like narrative or trans narrative in a
dialectic practice
especially if it can fit into
a worldview that reconciles in that
nested way
emergence and emanation together so we
don't just talk about it
we can actually if you and i paul could
enact
the coming together of emergence and
emanation
within an open-ended dialectic and then
that is an enacted symbol
of the way the logos of the universe
unfolds
is that narrative i don't know but it
feels very symbolic and it feels
like it's got a progression to it that
you guys seem to want in narrative
but it's not a typical narrative so
that's that's what i have to say about
that
one more point on this the bottom up in
the top down
that's for me relevance realization the
bottom up is the generation of variation
the enabling constraints
the top down is the selection etc and
that's how you get the
ongoing evolution of relevance
realization
so i think the machinery of relevance
realization
and the machinery of uh of the
intelligibility of things
that's found in the reconciliation of
emergence and emanation
i think they are deeply at one with each
other and that goes again to something i
got from jonathan
the idea that i've started to see in
both in some of the great
poets and in some of the neoplatonic
literature that there is a deep analogy
between how my my cognition is doing
relevance realization and taking the
combinatorial explosion of
indeterminacy and bringing it into
selected determination
and the way the universe as a whole has
got some principle that is moving
between
indeterminacy and determination again i
listen to jonathan
and so i think enacting that is that a
narrative i don't know but it's
something at least
symbolic and conversational um and
perhaps that's moving a little bit
towards
your guy's position so um
that's where things are at for me right
now i don't know if that's helpful
or if it's disruptive but that's my take
on what you asked for paul
that was helpful yeah i mean i
i think i think with the one of the
great things about talking with john is
is to what extent i feel like he really
does see
the he sees the things that i'm trying
to talk about and he has good words for
them and so
you know my of course i come from it in
turn less in terms of
the the scientific sense i i
i see it more within the human
horizon let's say and so i tend to use
my analogies tend to be more
related to um notions of emergence in
terms of the person
and how we are constituted how we're
constituted of of
many parts and how the manner in which
those the unity of our being and the
multiplicity of our being are joined
together
um and i tend to see that scale up
you know from the parts of a person into
a community
into larger communities and ultimately i
see that there is
the re the connection between the
cogside version the relevant realization
and the let's say the communal version
to me is completely linked together
because we don't have it
this is something i say all the time
there is no other perspective
right we don't have another perspective
besides
the perspective of the first person
within
consciousness perspective right we are
and so science ends up fitting let's say
fitting into the bigger
the bigger pattern for me is not the
scientific pattern the bigger pattern
is the pattern of of what you would call
the pattern of consciousness or the
pattern of meaning
the manner in which meaning manifests as
these two sides and then
science are just a bunch of examples of
how that
about that happen and so i i maybe i i
i'm kind of like a reverse
from science i have a lot of
appreciation for science because it
gives
good examples of places where this is so
i really am more of a neopl
platonius in like a very strict sense
but
one of the things that is amazing is how
what's happening
in the sciences and exactly what you
talked about about
this problem of the emerging qualities
and of
the patterns of noticing that there are
patterns to this emergence it's not just
anything goes there are patterns and
patterns which
also manifest themselves across
different emergent phenomena so you have
emergent phenomenas and then you notice
that there are there's a pattern of
emergence
which which is across the different
phenomena
i think that it's a key for modern
people to
go back into the the platonic tradition
we'll go back into aristotle
and understand what he was talking about
this is what he was talking about he was
talking about
body potential you know and essences or
these and how and the solution to me
is an incarnational principle is that
you
can't actually ultimately separate them
that they are they are meant to only be
embodied
and it's in only in the embodiment that
you encounter the
pattern and so you know that's the idea
of the resurrection in christianity in
the sense that
although sadly many christians many who
are very close to me
keep talking about going to heaven which
is just not
at all the real christian understanding
you christians don't go to heaven
right christians christian there is we
don't
we don't see the disembodied person
as a as the ultimate
realization of what the universe is
about you know we see
resurrection or a full manifestation
of the totality of the possibilities of
the body
with joining together with a
fullness of the essence of what that
thing is
that's the resurrection but it's it's an
it's also eschatological
in the sense that it doesn't happen in
the story
the story leads to it but it doesn't
happen in the story it happens
after the story whatever that means i
mean
in the sense that it's it's something
that it's like something that
history is pointing to but that it's
also happens beyond the point where
history stops and so it's not in the
story
the story is pointing to it but it
doesn't happen in the story
um that i think is also an important
aspect of the
of the christian story which that it it
it's pointing
towards things beyond itself which
are real realer than real like they're
they they're not imaginary they're not
uh
just phantasms but they they're they're
realer than real but they're also
not part of this world but they're not
they're not going to happen
in this world uh i don't know if that
makes sense in terms of understanding
what the the let's say the solution to
the problem of
the solution to the problem of this
thing is that it
can i say this we haven't we have a
perception of its
telos but its telos isn't
in the story right it actually
it actually it kind of leads towards and
then there's this
you know it's like a jump it's the same
jump as the emergent jump
right you can understand it that way
it's like it's a j imagine that
there's an emergence happening at every
level of reality
and there's a naming or a patterning and
that happens and then
there's everything and then there's
another jump and that jump
is beyond it's like it's it's beyond
everything
it's also it's also the communion of
everything
um so and it it breaks apart a little
bit of the
simplistic let's say eschatological
vision that
normal like i don't want to i don't i
hate bashing kind of normal people like
or just kind of the the regular
faith-going
christian um but it it offers a
possibility
for something which is more encompassing
than just a kind of basic understanding
that jesus is coming back and
you know he's going to judge the world
and we're all going to say which is
which is a great formulation i
i don't want to i don't like i said i
don't want to disparage it
but it it leaves it so even for the
person who believes it in a
in a kind of very basic way uh it'll
still
motivate their world in the same way as
someone who maybe has a higher
understanding of that story
and maybe that's also one of the things
that i think story does is that it
it makes that possible makes it possible
for everybody to participate
and not just because one of the things
that happens for example
in even in the groups that we're in and
the discussions we're in
is we end up being an elite because not
everybody has access to that
like not everybody has access to uh
guy saying stocks circling practices
like my my my second cousin
right doesn't have access to that or my
aunt
or because they don't they
they're they're living at a different
just level of
reality and so i think that that's also
one of the things that's
helpful in terms of i feel like i'm
rambling now but that narrative
is able to connect all these levels
because because of its pattern
because it it speaks in a very very
basic way and uses terms that everybody
can can relate to then it connects
everybody together
i i you know i i really connect with
what both of you were saying and i think
the
the differentiation between the finite
and the infinite games
is important and i see how
so so as a pastor i i live in a very
especially since my youtube career i
live in a very scaled world
i i minister to people with mental
impairments for whom
you know jesus died for my sins is
so that's the ins that's that that's the
verbal narrative instantiation
of of the story and it it's interesting
to me how
you know this the the the emergence and
the emanation
these these so map onto
you know the the heaven and earth
dichotomies
and and you see narratively how how
these
things sort of flesh themselves out one
of one of the things i was thinking
about john when i was listening to you
because you didn't mention it here
here yet but lately you know in our last
conversation we talked about the
the suchness and the moreness yes yes
and i think in some ways
part of what um part of what emanation
i think and the constraints you talked
about i'll throw another word in there
which is always difficult because
we like dualities because they focus
things for us
but that but the foundness the foundness
of the fact that
things things wrote things
as as jonathan always says things lay
themselves
out in in patterns that
not only we see repetition but we see
correlation between the patterns and we
see that
narratively it we see that
we see that working in narrative i think
we also
we also see that with these um
you know because there's all these weird
things in christianity that
if you look at the basic narratives and
you look at them a while and you look at
let's say the scriptures which is the
guide
especially in a protestant way for for
the laying out of these things
um they come to these funny conclusions
like when they ask jesus you know this
guy who
who who wound up married to seventh this
woman who mound up married to seven
brothers
who's he married to in the resurrection
and
you know you get to some of these weird
points where
jesus kind of says you your your
category no longer works you've come to
the end of this particular narrative
game yet an another piece from jonathan
that i picked up with one of his
conversations was
one of the real insights i got from
jordan peterson when he was talking
about the
the the reality of sacrifice
in human dynamics was he noted that part
of the difficulty we have
from a modernist perspective is we
imagine that
we in my words we imagine this
monarchical vision where there's
where there's no where there's no
narrative there's no culture there's
just
um there just is apart from
us and and jonathan mentioned but we're
patterned seeing patterns
so so the fact is as you said john
that physics seems to have have hit a
as seems to us have hit a wall and
there there there seems to be
correlation between the wall that
physics has hit
and and sort of i mean thomas nagel i
think
has brought some of this out that boy
isn't it interesting that that's that
same wall that we hit with respect to
all of the tricks we learned in
modernity of
of taking of attempting to take human
patterns out of the conversation
to see things as such to imagine we see
things as such but
wait a minute we're we're all human
beings
in these in these things and this
as you've said many times before too
john that
this narrative way of thinking it is not
necessarily our machine code is
something we learn when we're three or
four
it is simply so powerful
so pervasive that
at least conceptualizing
human beings getting beyond narrative
itself i i i simply doubt that any of us
are capable of that conceptualization
simply because it it it ruptures
exactly the suchness of what we see as
human beings
to be but but also because there's also
the question of
narrative in the sense that i think it's
also maybe
my notion of narrative is that it's also
a fractal there's a it has a fractal
structure and it goes from
it goes from just getting taking an
apple and
and bringing it to your mouth and
experiencing that satisfaction
and then throwing the core away that's a
story
that's a story that's a that's the same
story
as many larger larger
uh patterns that happen at a
multi-person level
and so to me that when i talk about
narrative and our experience of
the sense the the meaning of
a sequence of events it it it scales
down very low
in terms of of micro narratives that
that we encounter in our life but it
then it then it
those micro narratives then like
branches of trees and
and joining to a larger narrative end up
being what create
the higher narratives and higher higher
and higher narratives
um and so that's also one of the reasons
why i feel like we just
can't like it's impossible to
to avoid it because i i really do see it
as
i could even say as something which
might
be pushing it to a limit but i could say
that breathing
is a narrative breathing the
the in inhaling and exhaling is the
pattern of everything
right and and i'm not the first person
to say that obviously if you read
vedantic uh literature
they actually talk about the entire
reality all of reality as a breath of
the you know of uh
of the atma or or or the infinite as
this kind of
this bringing in a potential and then
producing you know this bringing in of
breath and this
ex expiration of breath it's life and
death it's everything
even in the pattern of the breath um
okay well you both have said as i
expected some very uh good things
about [ __ ] things and i'm glad that
you think that i take
i listen carefully because i do um and
so let me try a couple of responses
maybe from bottom up and top down
from bottom up you know um when you talk
to
people and i've got training in it who
do work in therapy and you know things
like cbt
it's often what's needed for people to
heal
is to realize that there isn't a
narrative there
um that there was no story for why the
truck
hit the woman that you love there's no
story there
you're trying to find the story you're
trying to come up with some
narrative you're trying to make the
universe fit into
a narrative framework and you're not
going to be able to do that
and you know and accepting that there
are aspects
of the universe that are beyond or
outside
the narrative framings of your life is
often i'm not speaking facetiously
this is often deeply therapeutically
beneficial to people
right you know uh you know why did what
why is he suffering there
well and well you know you're trying to
find a story you're trying to find a
purpose you're trying to find a tea loss
and that is really really suffering
now i want to acknowledge and i've
acknowledged it repeatedly with both you
guys
what i call the indispensability of
narrative we can't become temporarily
extended selves
without narrative i acknowledge all of
that and so we can't become moral agents
because you need in order to be a moral
agent you need to be a temporally
extended self
and it's clear that we learn narrative
to do that and i'm going to say
although it's not sufficient it's
certainly a necessary requirement for
being a person that you're a temporally
extended moral agent so that argument is
narrative is indispensable to being a
person
but aren't there aspects of
the of the universe like this is the
therapeutic context
that are properly thought of as being
impersonal
um right and so in the sense that
thinking that they operate according to
the patterns and principles
of personhood and personality those are
not the same thing
those are not the same thing but let's
group them together because narrative
deals with personality and personhood
right that's what narrative is about to
my mind um so i i i'll
maybe we can go back to the breathing
thing in a bit jonathan uh and so
bottom up i think that you know and you
see this
throughout stoicism is a big recognition
that there is the logos
right there is intelligibility but right
the the
the that to expect that to operate
according to the principles and
what do i want to call the principles
and patterns of personality and
personhood
is a mistake now remember i did
acknowledge a deep analogy
between relevance realization and what
the manifestation of intelligibility we
want to put it that way
the metaphysics of intelligibility but
it seems to me that there are many
instances
where right people find
a special healing and then that gets
taken up clearly within the mystical
tradition
where people clearly report states and i
do experimental work on this
that are not like non-personality or
supra personal and supra narrative
and i think you even see hints of this
if you'll allow me
i always feel like i'm treading on
around when i do this but i'm very
influenced by the theology of sally
mcfag and the work she's done
on parables both within the christian
tradition and especially within the sufi
tradition
and she points out the point of a
parable is to sucker you in
to a narrative framework that then
undermines itself as a story
like what's the story of the prodigal
son well i can tell you
sort of this sequence of events but
what's the narrative there well
good luck because it's an infinite game
right
i can't tell you what the story is and
she says that's the point
because there is no final t loss no
final reconciliation between justice
and compassion etc and if we try to
resolve
that we present that's precisely where
we lose
our humanity it's only in preserving the
tension in a non-narrative fashion
that we preserve our humanity so i'm
trying to show you sort of top down
and bottom up there seems to be lots of
instances
where you know again again acknowledging
the indispensability of narrative to
personhood
it's both therapeutic and also
transcendent
to to realize the non-narrative
and to realize that i think it's even
impregnated
in a lot of the you know the
parables and allegories uh it's in the
plato's allegory of the cave it sounds
like a story but it's not a story
uh because when he sees the sun his you
know his mind is blowing open
and and so i think
i think that you're right i i think that
you're right
what you're saying is completely right
on okay but i think it's right on
i think that it's maybe the reason why
we're finding some kind of
clash or we're not totally agreeing is
that maybe it's because i
i haven't mentioned or i haven't clearly
stated that
this the the narrative the story
the only story let's say
is the story of the is the breakdown in
meaning
right that's the story that's the story
i
i'm sorry to say it's like the story is
always a breakdown in meaning that's
always what a story is
a story is a breakdown in meaning and
then
a recapturing of meaning in a different
manner that's why i talk about breathing
in and breathing out or
or you know it's always a fall and a
standing up it's always going down into
the belly of the whale
and crying out and then coming back up
right it's always
job who is suffering without reason
and is calling out to to and sometimes
he doesn't even get
a reason right and you see that in even
the story
of christ who on the cross says why have
you abandoned me
okay so to me that is the the story
uh and so i i think a good way to
understand it maybe to understand it
in like a three-tiered structure you
could say
so you have you have beyond
beyond meaning you have the absolute or
you have the mystical
ex direct vision which goes beyond
narrative right which is above narrative
and then you also have death chaos and
death
which is this breakdown in meaning in a
negative sense where
things are scattered and fractured and
and they cause suffering okay and so
you have these two sides and then in the
middle
which is the actually most of the time
the world we
navigate in that's where the story
happens
and the story ends up being a
negotiation between these two parts
these two aspects
that which transcends meaning and that
the meaning and that which is below and
is a breakdown of meaning
right so you understand this the story
as a pyramid as a
as a mountain right i always talk about
this this image of the mountain
so you have which is above the light
coming down and then you have the thorns
and the
ocean and the leviathan at the bottom of
the
of this of the mountain okay and so
and so there is of course like you said
there is in for example in that person
who has
is hit by a bus that's what they've
they've just been tossed into the sea
that's exactly what's happened to them
they've been thrown to the to the shark
they
they've been eaten by a fish and now
they're going down into
the into the water and they're searching
for meaning they're looking around and
they're saying where is it
where where is the meaning there's no
meaning this is painful this is
suffering
and then there is this
reconciliation this this reconciliation
which has to happen
you know and it can be a letting go of a
desire for
a false meaning it can be all kinds of
possibilities
of letting go of a false narrative but
then they need
to get back out of the water they're
gonna have to find another narrative
right that person got hit by a bus and
is in the hospital and it has broken
legs and broken
limbs and is searching for meaning to
understand
why it happened to them as they let go
of that
search for a kind of break a broken
narrative
if they're going to get out of the
hospital and start their life again
they're going to have to find a new
story
there's going to have to a new story is
gonna have to manifest itself
and so to me that's how i see the
the narrative now the mystery and this
is the biggest mystery of
all and this is the biggest mystery of
christ is
that what christ is showing us is that
ultimately and this is the very
disturbing disturbing thing that i'm
going to say
but ultimately what's up here and what's
down here
they're the same you
you you have to you can reach a point
where
the cross is at the top of the mountain
which is like it it blows your mind
because it's
it's it's it's actually saying that not
the non-duality
encompasses both the breakdown of
meaning
and the trans the transcendence of
meaning
yeah um and it's something that it's
hard it's like i said it's hard to deal
because it just breaks everything in
your mind
um but but that's to me that's how i see
the importance of narrative the man in
which it's transcended the manner in
which it brings us into death
and then ultimately how i think the the
story itself is
transcended in a way that's hard to
fathom in the story of the crucifixion
well don't go john okay sorry uh i
i've confidence in the fact that um it's
sort of your turn to speak paul's i'll
try to keep this brief
um so so
that i think that was really cool um and
i don't mean that in
a dismissive fashion um i think
i i think that metaphor and symbol and
narrative
are all our continuum of
things we do that we learn kids also
have to learn metaphor they're not
naturally metaphorical
they have to learn humor right they have
to learn symbol um
and and i mean i think that's purely
and so i think these this is the
indispensable arena in which we train
the non-logical identity that you talked
about because the identity you talked
about at the end
they're the same you're clearly not
making that a logical identity
it's it's translogical and i think
narrative
like the parables and you even said this
like you
they they they are an affordance but
they're a springboard to something
beyond it
because it sounds to me sorry i don't
want to impose it sounds to me like
you're saying
the the the the principle that makes
whatever it is that's making narrative
is not itself narrative
um and and what i'm wondering
is if that's sort of ultimately
reconcilable
with you know a scientific world view
that sees things in non-teleological
terms
that's one part of what i want to say
the other part is
the which is a problem i keep coming
back to
which is the problem of pluralism i get
i get the idea of
encompassing narratives that reach from
the depths of the emergence to the
height of emanation and
bind them together symbol on non-logical
identity i get that
i acknowledge it but what i see and this
is the post-modern
influence on me right i see multiple
versions of these
i mean you guys even have different
versions of christianity
all right uh not and i'm not trying to
be insulted
right and different traditions and and
so
while i acknowledge everything you you
say jonathan
and i think i'm acknowledging it quite
sincerely and deeply
the you know the the the sort of the
this
this triangle of pluralism
that we also have you know we also have
this scientific discourse
that has made tremendous progress by
going non-narrative
and that's pretty undeniable and then we
have
the other fact of the
pluralism of these grand narratives as
also an undeniable fact for people
uh and so that's why i
and i hesitate to i to say there is
the story uh that's that's that's what's
problematic for me
yeah i understand i understand what
you're saying in terms of
the story there's only let's say there's
only instantiations of the story too
there
there is the story all the
the different instantiations of the
story point to
a story which is in a manner beyond the
its manifestation the pattern of
everything right
so so necessarily that's also the one of
the things that you get
at the top of the mountain right so
you you get you so you have this side
like in in segregate there's a really
wonderful way of explaining it which is
that moses
is on the mountain and he's he's he goes
up the mountain
and so in order to go up the mountain he
does
actually have to kind of strip away the
outer layers of himself
kind of strips away and strips away then
when he gets into
the highest point of the mountain god
gives him the pattern of the tabernacle
he gives them the pattern and
but you understand that the only way
that we can encounter the pattern of the
tabernacle
he says crazy things he says things like
the pattern of the tabernacle which is
christ himself
it's like read the story it's describing
a building it's not describing
the anointed one it's not describing the
messiah but what he's trying to show you
is
to say that he encountered the pattern
he encountered the logos itself but
when when it's written in the text it's
it's a building
because they're what else are you going
to do it has to come down
it has to come down the mountain he
receives the law in a pure form he
he sees the divine light but when he
comes down he has to have tablets with
things written on them
and so he and those and those things are
not i'm not and i want to disparage the
law
in the sense that it's a that it's that
it's just uh
a form or it's just a covering but it is
a covering
and but it's a covering that manifests
that which is beyond it
so moses wears a veil on his face the
veil that moses wears on his face
is the law those two things are the same
he's coming down the mountain and he's
showing and so it's like
it's funny because i hate to use it's
funny i'm going to use the i'm going to
use a hindu text to talk about
to talk about christianity but that's
the to me that's what
happens in the bhagavad-gita yeah yes
yes right so arjuna
sees krishna but he can't it's
unbearable to see
that it's it's too much it's it's
overwhelming it's it's an
explosion of unity and multiplicity and
it's like he sees
he sees divinity and it's not and then
he's like but then what's krishna
telling him to do
he's basically he's saying like why
would i fight like why would i fight
because there's
this the same problem you're saying
there's these multiple stories and
there's these different things and all
these things so it's like i've i'm
brought
into a kind of lethargy where i can't
act
because there's all these different
these all these different paths and all
these different
roads that lead you know up the mountain
and and krishna is saying
take your sword go fight you have to be
on a
you have to be on a path there's no
other way you have to be
on the on an actual road that leads you
up the mountain
and that road is is as real as it's
going to get until you
reach the the divine vision
and i can't talk for what happens after
that
who can speak for what happens after
that well i mean i like
i i mean i i like that you brought in
the bhagavad-gita and how you know
krishna
uh gloss grows through a pluralism now
i've become deaf right and now i'm
become this
and now i'm from that and it's the
trajectory through all of the
instantiations that uh that arjuna is
supposed to pick up on
and so i agree with that um and
the idea that that sort of behind beyond
but beneath the stories
is the logos but what i what what what
i'm suggesting is
maybe a better model for the logos than
story is via logos
is what we're doing now that this is and
there's a reason why it's called the
logos i think a better model for the
logos
is via logos what's happening here this
unexpected
unpredictable unfolding of relevance
realization and meaning making
and that's a better and more right
a better metaphor a better symbol for
the logos
than the telling of stories that's to me
uh better that's what i'm proposing it's
it's interesting to me in conversations
like this i i often ask myself
okay where where where is the where is
the disagreement and what is the
disagreement about
in in your
because you know i i've got a lot of
experience um
john in the illustration that you used
of the woman
who is hit by a is hit by a truck
and because that there's you know and i
i think jonathan
really nicely sort of laid out the meta
story
um what what exactly is a story and
another way to frame it it's interesting
and nt writes
in his magisterial work uh his first
volume he goes
first thing he one first thing he gets
into in terms of his prologument is what
is a story
and another conceptualization of it is
you have shalom the breakdown of shalom
and the recapture of shalom and this is
a
this is a and this is in many ways
also gets that jonathan framed it in
terms of meaning you could frame it in
terms of shalom but it's this basic
movement
from you know creation fall redemption
and
more of the you know the classic
statement of my own tradition
it's it always strikes me the um
what is what exactly is the consolation
what exactly is the consolation of
hearing
that the um the the accident with the
truck
was was a product you know there was
there was no purpose behind it there was
and and to me
this this is where we bump up into the
where this conversation bumps up
into consciousness and persons and i i
you know i've been doing a ton of
thinking about persons over the last two
years
in terms of what persons are because
there is this
there is this emergent quality to to
personhood
and the connection to our physiology
and the um our histories i mean all of
this is evident
and in personhood cognitive science
psychology has
has illuminated so many of those
connections
yet when it comes to the story of the
truck accident
so often what i see
how it boils down in the lives of people
is that
um father meant me no harm
or there wasn't a there wasn't uh this
this gets into this this archetypal
thing
that what what crushes people often in
christianity especially in
a very uh robust version
of christianity which is calvinism which
very much accentuates personhood
through and through where you know
all all of the all of the evil that
comes to me
is brought to me by my father by my
father's hand
and you know this gets really weird in
some calvinist circles
but but but therapeutically
pastorally theologically you can
see these moves and and i think it's
interesting in christianity
in the in the hebrew scriptures where
among the background of a
among the background of creation
narratives
which are simply replete with persons
free agents as you will small g gods
the son is a god the moon is a god the
you know every
everything's just replete with gods you
get this story at the beginning of
genesis where there's
there's there's one consciousness
um you know and and the sun is a
functionary
but you don't pray to the sun and the
moon is the moon governs by night
but you don't pray to the moon um you
know in the words of saint francis it
might be
brother son sister moon but but even
that formulation
relativizes my personhood
with respect to the source
personhood of which my personhood is
butter reflection
as even in a sense the sun and the moon
are
even though we don't treat them as
persons they are
they are obedient functionaries
but in a sense non-conscious so
so in a funny way you know so what i'm
trying to do is to
begin to get a sense of okay so we've
got
someone advocating for the meta story
and
and and i think jonathan articulated so
well and and john you articulated well
and
i wonder okay where's where's where's
the disagreement here and
and not in the spirit of saying you know
well let's let's paper over these
disagreements so we can all hold hands
and sing kumbaya but but much more in
the spirit of dialogues where
we're saying okay i i understand
jonathan a little bit better
and i understand john a little bit
better and and i might even see some mat
some mutual mappings that i didn't see
before
but but i i very much understand both of
you
where um you know all of the usual
suspects that we're dealing with now in
terms of our meaning making
are at play in this conversation between
you two
and the different traditions that that
they they're they're not simply the same
thing as people like to sort of facility
jump to oh they're all talking about the
same thing it's all
there's no disagreement there none of us
are doing that so it's just
interesting listening to you both and
and looking at the mappings and saying
very interesting put that on my
tombstone
my life it was very interesting
i don't know if that leads either of you
to anywhere i mean i can maybe
steal man john's position in the sense
that i understand
his his suspicion of let's say story and
or
the united suspicion of inhabiting a
story in the sense that
that that leads to war it does it really
does and it happens
all through the all through human
history where
inhabiting identities and inhabiting
uh stories will lead you into conflict
with
people who have other stories and and
the fact that john
is mentioning that there are these other
passages others religion there are
different types of christianity there
are different you know um ways of
of practicing religion that that
that shows this difficulty which is
how if you inhabit a path if you if you
take on this path as a story and you you
move you enter into a story then you're
going to find yourself in competition
with other stories and the dangers that
we fall back
onto a kind of tribal kind of type of
tribal warfare that
has plagued human history so it do you
think that i'm right in terms of
understanding the re one of the reasons
let's say why you're
you want you're careful with that that
idea
i think that's fair and then i would add
one element i think that's implicit
which is the idea that story
comes to an end and that what i need to
do therefore is end
other stories so that the only ending is
my story's ending
um and i don't think so i i think
there's a deep connection
uh between i see some of the things
you're saying is saying that there are
narratives that are non-teleological
i wanna i wanna leave that open i don't
wanna impose on you so
right because i think breathing isn't i
don't want breathing to end that would
be a mistake right
i don't wanna i don't wanna i don't
wanna complete that process it's not a
finite game it's an infinite game
uh if i take the metaphor correctly but
i think where
that for many standard
interpretations of what narrative means
is narrative
is teleological and i find on one hand
that problematic with respect to science
i've already mentioned that
but i also find it problematic because i
think there is a
deep connection between uh and this is
what james cars argues
between tediology finite game
and yeah conflict warfare yes i think
those are
inherently bound together in a powerful
way
because if the point is to get to x and
you say no the point is to get to y
and it's often the case well i've got to
shut you up so that we get to x
um and that's and you know and and
warfare narratives are exactly that kind
of narrative
that's exactly the kind of narrative
there are there are tediological
narratives in which i try to crush
one key loss so that my two loss is
realized yeah so
did i did did i respond in kind to you
no i think i think you're right i think
you're right it's also one of the
reasons why
i i'm i'm trying to point out
the idea of eschatological storytelling
which is what which is what many
religions have not just christianity
islam and buddhism
and hinduism and judaism all have
eschatological storytelling
which is that the the resolution of
their story
happens in another age happens in
in an age beyond ages or an age of ages
where you know the final the final
manifestation of
of uh the final buddha will create
will restore a new cycle it doesn't
there are different ways of
of putting it in terms of christianity
it's the you know the new jerusalem
the messianic age another age
and so what because the the storytelling
is eschatological
it pushes this the resolution of the
story
outside of the story or outside of the
outside of the possibility of like a
movie where the movie has a
has an ending the the the story has an
ending but that
ending is not in the story
and and i think in a lot of the work
that i've done i think
that is actually a
a critical feature to
actually having human communities have
stable stories
because there are elements of the story
that if
brought off into a new age
afford um afford the
the pulling back of too many finite
stories
miroslav wolfe makes this point in the
breakdown of yugoslavia
he noticed that it was the it was the
the the secular atheist descendants of
communist who must settle scores in this
age
because there was not a new age in which
another age
in which the scores would finally be
settled and so what miroslav wolf noted
is that there's a with with
and i think i think part of the
scientific frame
that pushes us towards this is that now
there's only this frame
and when there's only this frame all
games
must suddenly become finite
and it actually intensifies the
narrative conflicts between
us which produces more bloodshed
and so in this way there's sort of an
ironic relationship between
this this dance of finite and infinite
stories
i i that's a good point paul and what
you just said jonathan
uh it makes your
i don't know if you've read uh mick [ __ ]
but um
uh her metaphorical theology and her
speaking in parables
uh but your sense of narrative is very
much
and again but it sounds more
trans-narrative
like it sounds like the the the point of
the story is to throw you
outside of the story um like the
parables
and and the point about the parabol well
sorry
i'm doing what i said you should one
lesson i have learned from
the peripheral of the prodigal son and
carol shields does an excellent version
of this in the story she wrote
that's an allegory of the prodigal son
is that
the attempt to find a resolution between
justice and compassion
isn't something we should do right we
shouldn't do that we will lose our
humanity
and here's where i'm influenced by
tillich like all you know he talks about
all these tone-offs
the attempt to resolve the needs for
individuation and par
and participation we shouldn't do that
we shouldn't try to resolve those
tensions
right we shouldn't try to bring them uh
to resolution
so i guess the the the the thing i'm
trying to negotiate here with you
and i feel like this is genuine sort of
deal logos
is right what does it
mean then right there's two things
you're saying
right we want to there's a sense in
which the part of the infinite game is
to keep the tensions alive if you'll
allow me that
because that's where we preserve our
humanity and
again this is a theological argument uh
tilik makes it repeatedly
it's not i'm not something it's not
something i'm imposing on christianity
from without
um so um and and then
and i'll bring in jordan peterson you
know after you play all the games you
have to constantly remember that you're
playing the metagame
and the metagame and the point is never
to end the metagame
never to never to get it and sometimes
you win and sometimes you lose and if
you try to always
win you've actually lost the metagame
right and
these are the concerns i'm bringing in
now
if what you said is right paul there's
a sense in which like is
is is the age beyond all ages um which
sounds like
to me like the god beyond all gods but
we'll go back to that another time
is the age beyond all ages is it a
promised land
or is it a horizon
because if it's it can do it can
function the way you both said
if it's just a horizon of
intelligibility not a promised land that
we'll get to
where all these tensions will finally be
resolved and
everything will come to some kind of un
un inhuman i want to say inhuman peace
because i don't want that a human in
human peace and i don't know why anybody
should recommend it to me
um and so that's kind of uh yeah
i'm trying to play well i i i try to
play your ballpark look at least in
the at least in most underst orthodox
understanding there is that is that
deification is a is a eternally dynamic
process
yeah the epic cases right and so if that
and so there isn't this idea
of the coming age as we're all gonna be
sitting on clouds
with uh harps you know that kind of
cliche and this
and just bored you know whatever and uh
that
there really is this idea that it's a
that it's from glory to glory
infinite infinite movement from glory to
glory and that there is no
there is no finnish line
oh well as you know and i mentioned it
in my series i i like the eastern
orthodox
idea of epictasis i think i uh i i
i i sort of see that um
and i think that goes back to the
vedanta it's the
right you're not supposed to latch on to
any one of the manifestations of krishna
it's the art it's the infinite
trajectory it's that it's the way that
trajectory points to beyond all the
manifestation that gives you the sense
of divinity
but that sounds to me then that
the answer to my question is that the uh
the age beyond ages is a horizon
not rather than a promised land but i
think the images
i think they can be both i think it can
be both at the same time and i think
it's how about this the promised land is
a is a mountain
an infinite mountain that has that that
it's whose summit reaches
into infinity see i i wouldn't i
wouldn't phrase it now i'm going to
put on the theological what theologians
do is
quibble about words and distinctions
i i wouldn't phrase it as age beyond
ages because that
that sort of that sort of just sort of
punts it out into
nothingness whereas i you know one of my
favorite
articulations of this is c.s lewis's
children's book the last battle
where it's further up and further in
and and where you know right now
we right now we get this neil degrasse
tyson at this very interesting
conversation where he said you know
that we have this funny dynamic that the
more we know
the more we realize we don't know
because with each increase
with each increasing vista we see more
vistas
and well that's a curious aspect about
reality we would have thought we'd have
got to the bottom of it and
and we we you know for all of we haven't
been doing it that long but
we don't seem to really be getting to
the bottom of it and and
and so cs lewis in the last battle and
he's it's very interesting
at lewis's point in his life he starts
writing children's book this man who
seemed to know no children
nor have reason to know children um
starts writing these children's books
and then i
is the last battle is my favorite of
those books because you have this sense
of
you know suddenly the children discover
true narnia well then
you know of course this gets deeply into
philosophy because it's lewis but
and and then their their quest is to go
further up and further in and you have
the same sense
in in the great divorce his book about
um in some ways the age to come and
christianity has always recognized that
the images we have of
the next age at least because let's not
pal let's not try to posit every age
but let's just be content with at least
the next one
um they're all of our all of our images
are evocative
they're all limited but
i think in many ways they do function
as necessary elements for us to
manage the age we have and to not
concern ourselves too much
about the age to come and again this is
sort of where my calvinism
kicks in because finally all of those
questions get punted to
well if there is in fact such a god then
and if this god
is in fact good and right then he will
finally do what's
do what's right with it so and and
that's
obviously very pastoral move but but
i love the i love the cs lewis image i
think it's a beautiful image
and it's it's a very powerful image and
it also
helps to understand that that at least
at least my understanding when i read
the father's and i read the mystics is
that
the age to come is also now it's also
now it's not just the age to come
it's it's it's that even in the now
which is beyond
what what is immediately accessible to
us in terms of
seeing the glory of god you could see it
that way or seeing the radiance of the
glory of god in the world and so it's
not just a
it's not it it's that it's it's an age
to come and
when you talk about it in terms of let's
say the cosmic story but it's accessible
to the mystics now that aids to come
like they're already
we already we see that in the text where
they talk about
you know that there are some saints that
are already in the resurrection that
they
they already participate in the
resurrected in the resurrected body
um and so it's not just a
it it doesn't just have a narrative
function it has an ontological
reality which we can participate in
that's how i interpreted the up and it
always up and in
um it's neoplatonic which of course is
why jonathan likes it
and while lewis probably picked it up
from well of course i mean
what does he say in the magician's
nephew it's all in plato i don't know
what they're teaching
children these days um so um
and so but that that to me
i i yeah i mean but isn't i mean
neoplatonism is basically
the the vertical ontology rather than
the narrative horizontal
moving because right the horizontal
moving towards the horizon
that's the narrative structure but and
and but the the what the the plateness
and the stoics say ultimately is
no no and i go back to one of jonathan's
point where you should ultimately set
your identity
isn't this way this is practical i'll
use buddhist terms this is the
this is you know this is relatively
useful for getting around in your life
but where you should ultimately set your
identity is
in right is on in that ontological
relation
that's why the narrative is actually not
going towards the horizon it's going up
and down a mountain
it's it's it's it's they join together
right the the
yours the story of your life becomes
your struggle to
go up and down the the ontological
mountain that and and that's what the
story is again it's
it is the fall from it's going down the
the mountain falling tumbling
falling into the water and then going
back up
somehow or joining the two extremes
together um
and and to reframe it in a pastoral
sense
um this also maps on to the command to
love and i
you know i started a little clips
channel and i john i used your clip
at the end of 15 i think it was of agape
and just last night at a meet-up one of
the people
you watched my said i've never seen john
verviki talk about agape like that
and i've seen so many christians just
just light up
when when they when they heard that and
and so in a sense
the so so we're talking all these
symbolic ways but
the very pastoral way to love your
neighbor
is in many ways many of these things
just simply
map onto that because loving your
neighbor is like climbing a mountain
and it's often falling from the mountain
and
and because well and and it's and it's
loving a person
and and one of the things that you
immediately
you immediately get into when you start
trying to love a person
is all of the deconstructed
um grime of that person where they've
they've taken on all these bad habits
and i have all this
crappy thinking and and all of this
self-deception
and so even in that journey which jesus
basically boils down to okay well let's
you know i gotta make it real simple and
scalable for all of you
i want to i want you to love your
neighbor and that's in a sense where
your journey begins
and and i think even in the sense of
beginning that journey anyone who loves
their neighbor
imaginatively engages a narrative
that says i i imagine
for my neighbor a a
blessedness that at this point they can
neither comprehend
nor nor nor attain
and so my love in itself will
it won't guarantee but it will be an
affordance
and a a pathway up the mountain
with them
okay well that i mean i i
i i'm in deep agreement with that i
guess
i my i think that
the uh i don't know if i'm making i'm
not making an account argument i think
i'm just putting on another dimension
but maybe it'll turn into a counter
argument because i'm trained that way
but
because i'm doing a deep dive in this if
you if you dive deeply into platonic
dialectic
and you can but you can see it uh seated
in socrates
those two dimensions and jesus gives two
commands love the
love god with all your and then love
your neighbor as yourself
and i think of those the first command
is the vertical and the second is the
horizontal
and like jonathan said what dialogue
what dialectic does and this is how i
see it being trans
narrative is that it says those two
are always there i i think of them
almost like
the the x and y on a cartesian graph and
right and then there's the third
dimension that emerges from them the
third factor that's neither the
horizontal nor the vertical
but you know that that which grounds the
two of them together
uh if you'll if you'll allow me and that
i think this is
something about what puts eminence
emergence and emanation together but
that's getting very abstract let's bring
it down to it this is what i'm trying to
what i'm trying to say
that when i when loving you isn't
telling a story about you
ultimately it's about entering into
dialogue that
you know that is constantly moving back
in the tone-offs between your
individuation and participation
my individuation in part and that
dialogue that logos that emerges between
us that intimacy
for me right that also that pre-figures
i'll use a christian
word it prefigures the intimacy i can
have with the vertical
logos and makes the two resonate
together
and so for me that's what that's what
i'm trying to propose when i'm
trying to propose dialogue but maybe the
difference between these two is now
disappearing
i'm proposing that as maybe
oh wow this is going to be pretentious
the gods are going to strike me down for
hubris
maybe that is a better metaphor for the
coming age
an enacted symbol of the logos than
story because we need
something that will allow all of these
emerging communities
to dialogue with each other i think
dialogue is really really important
uh right now and that sounds like such a
you know
united nations platitude and that's not
what i'm trying to get at i'm trying to
get at
a form of human discourse that is doing
what we're doing
now and and so i don't think it should
allow me
i i i don't think that any one of our
stories
is i'll try and use cap is the
appropriate symbol for the sacred i
think the ongoing
dialogue between us is the best
symbol for the sacred and it's one we
can enact in love
horizontal and vertical love right now
yeah but but i also i don't think how
can i say this i don't think that
that those two are exclusionary of each
other like i
i don't think that maybe they're not i'm
willing to see that i'm willing to
concede that and so
so i think that so imagine it like
like a a good way to maybe to imagine
it's imagining like a dance
right and so we we're dancing
and that dance has a has a pattern
and that pattern will express
itself in terms of communion in a
immediate sense right in in the sense
that you talk about in the sense of this
exchange and this finding of of
places where we connect and then also
this kind of accepting and
relinquishing the places where we aren't
connected and so there's this breathing
in and breathing out in the discussion
where we connect and disconnect and but
we
still continue to to dance right in this
discussion
and so i think that that's definitely
that's definitely
a a powerful and and like you said
a good image of uh of the sacred
and and i think it's great i think it's
wonderful um but
but like i said because i think that i
think that if
we can't avoid being in uh
a story which scales at all these
different levels that i talk about
i feel like if we ignore it or if we try
to
cast it aside just like any pattern if
you try to
to to to set it aside it's going to
it's going to take its revenge on you
it's going to it's going to come back
right just like not sleeping like i talk
about you don't sleep and you think that
sleeping
sleeping is is not useful then it's
gonna come back
and i think that that's what i think
that because we're seeing
a because we're seeing this narrative
burning right now all around especially
in the in the west
we also have to be able to find ways to
to reconcile ourselves within these
stories and to find
our place let's say to find the way in
which we fit into
these stories as well um like
and so i think that that's why i think
that i i
i i totally agree with what you said but
i also
think that we have to we have to be in a
in a story and if we don't
it's going to happen to us when we began
i really liked how both of you so we've
got the we've got the emergence from
below and in a sense we're all
living in that emergence and
we're you know our relevance realization
is is all the time because we
we understand the terror of of falling
back down the mountain and we understand
so so we're all in the emergence but but
the the emanation
i think with a vision of the emanation
one can have hope in in the emergent
process that the the
the emergence will not be futile now
now it's a weird thing because on one
hand if you
if you emphasize the emanation too
strongly
i think as you said jonathan you get
this tyrannical
and and you also squelch that i love how
john i'd never put that together where
your relevance realization is is sort of
right at the border between those two
things
yeah yeah yeah and that both drives us
into the narrative it drives us into the
future
and and this is one thing that you know
i i i have when i think about the age to
come
my anxiety about the age to come is well
what do you mean there's no more c
in the book of revelation because that's
symbolic of
you know of sort of chaos being put to
rest and we'll ripe every tier and all
of that but
but but so right now you both
need the the anxiety
and the the
narrat the meaning because again meaning
is right in there too the meaning
of the of the quest in
the at the emergent level where we're
struggling
up but yet also the confidence of the
of the emanation that this this is
you know finally this is not purposeless
finally this seeks towards a
a a a a telos
even though we understand that you do
have finite and infinite games and so i
you know again just listening to both of
you and taking from both of you
i i really find a lot of useful things
to help me
as the protestant here kind of in
between the two of you
but in terms of meaning it's really the
idea of the escotala the eschatology is
also important
in terms of understanding this problem
of meaning which is that meeting is post
hoc quite often and it's also
fine that it's post hoc we don't have to
see that as
negative we don't have to see it as
negative that meaning is revealed
after the fact and that meaning
comes together after we've you know like
that person who
that person who who gets hit by a bus
and
it's all meaningless and they're in the
hospital and everything and then
they they they can't do the job that
they were going to do
and so finally they have to go to school
and study something else and then they
end up doing
some other job and then they say oh
that's why i got hit by a bus
and then you look at them and you think
are you silly person you're just
you're just putting the pattern back on
to what happened
but no no no that's exactly how things
work
and it's fine that they work that way
and the the vision of
of the of eschatology has to do with a
universal version of that which is that
the logos
judges at the end meaning
the final meaning will be will be given
at the end
right just like a movie with a with a
fishtail ending
like that it's only at the end that you
see the full meaning
and that's not a negative thing it's
just it's actually part of the
the pattern as well that the final
meaning
is pushed into the future
and it's weird because people it's like
postmoderns have used that to
to like basically destroy you know
they've used that pattern to notice how
meaning comes after
to basically destroy all kind of
essentialism but i'm like no
i don't think that destroys it i think
that's actually how
it also works because you have darkness
comes before the light even in the gen
in the genesis creation story
the chaos is there before light and
that's just how it works
oh sorry jonathan no no no well i'm
going to play i'm going to i'm going to
play
with this a little bit go for it
scientists because
the phenomena that you talked about i
mean that's very much the phenomena of
reconstructive memory
right uh that uh so a good metaphor this
is our meta our memories are not like
computer files
our memory are is like a compost
whatever is
most recent is fairly accurate but as
you go backwards in time
uh things get meshed and confused
together
and that's what you all the memory
research uh since about
1980 elizabeth loftus on and that's why
people can
you can it's easy to implant uh false
memories in people
i think you know i think you get get
people right now get them in a room and
uh get them to imagine doing something
come back
to them six months and ask them if they
did it or not and they're likely to say
that they did it
even though they imagined doing it and
and they the the examples of these
are are replete this is one of the
problems with sort of the idea that our
self is a stable entity
because that story is is um rewriting
itself but
part of that rewriting is undermining
and so
we do this all the time and one of the
concerns of the post-modernists
you guys are putting me in the weird
position of defending i think there's
value in post-modernism i think
i think there's value okay okay good
okay great because um that's where
that's one of the places where jordan
jordan peterson and i bought heads i
think uh i'm in an innovation yeah
i i told you i tell jordan in the
comments conversation with him that i
think he doesn't understand
jacques you know and there's deep
connections between darada
and negative theology there's a you know
wonderful work on that
the influence of derrida on caputo and
mark taylor who are amazing theologians
i mean that that's just that's just
there or foucault's you know deep
reflections on stoicism
and the technologies of the self and the
work of pierre head oh that's all there
too
right there but the concern
uh uh is the what the postmodernists and
that's what i'm trying to do with the
example
is they're trying to say but we have a
pretense of the stability of the
narrative that is not true
that that that that event you got where
the guy goes back he said well that's
great
but you know that's reconstructive
memory and that's exactly what makes
the idea that there's a narrow that's
what d stick postmod
if post-modernism is anything it's an
attempt to destabilize
our culture of cognitive grammar and
show that it's much less stable than we
pretend it is and just like we pretend
that we have a stable self
right and that our memories are accurate
what we realize is actually our self
isn't so stable
and our memories are mostly false and
so but what if what if that
that pattern the manner in which ain't
older events mesh into themselves
what if that is actually a very useful
way to see patterns
because it is it's like i love the
legends of alexander the great because
there are some of the most mythical
mystically powerful stories that
that you can find because they seem to
have been
through that that grinder that you talk
about and i think that
i could i would even dare say go as far
as to saying
that i think that the the story in
genesis 1 that's what happened
it's just it's at a cosmic scale and so
what's left in the story of genesis is
it
is is a is a telling of something that
happened
but has been brought into
such patterning that it has it's
it's represented only in universal
categories
that's cool jonathan that's very cool
because when i teach my students about
this
i say the point of memory is not
an accurate reporter of the past but an
intelligent anticipator of the future
um and so um
is that basically what you're saying is
is that how i should understand it
well i think it's mostly that i think
that memory
is there to let's say especially ancient
memory
is the is a patterning mechanism it's
not to remember accurately
things in the past it's there to
recognize the pattern of being so that
well maybe you could see it the way you
said so that you can encounter that
pattern as it
as it manifests itself to you in in the
world
right now it's the importing of good
learning uh
basically with what we're talking about
because that's what you mean by pattern
detection ultimately right
i mean yeah that could be it i'm not
sure about the term you use i never
heard it but i i
and i i think you know we're bumping
into modernity again here
and we have to give modernity it's due
because when you say the pretense of the
stability of the narrative that is not
true and what we're saying is that
you know sally really didn't go to the
park on november 31.
um you know and there's there's an
interesting discussion in the cs lewis
community about the date
i mean c.s lewis was horrible with dates
and he seemed to completely get
wrong his conversion story which is a
seminal moment and
it's like how could you get that how
could you get the timing of this wrong
alistair mcgrath has a
whole biography nearly half devoted to
this
issue um you know part of part of
part of the reason modernity arrived and
was so potent
and was so you know was so productive
for us was it it demanded the the
correlation to a certain
um to it to a certain layer of our
reality
but but those correlations i mean what
jonathan and i continually deal with
with our audiences
given all the deep impact of modernity
on the reading of the biblical text
which is a pre-modern text
obviously is well how how are we in fact
to
to put all these layers together and
and that also maps onto our questions of
let's say the next age because do
i participate in this well what am i
and what on earth does resurrection mean
um and this resurrection of jesus christ
and
i mean so you know we we have to on one
hand give modernity
it's due in that sally did not go to the
park this day and that is a that is a
memory she has
and you know even if so i've been
married longer you know i've been
married for 32 years
and it's amazing the um the kinds of
conversations you'll have with a spouse
in terms of what she remembers on what i
remember and
you know i used to do those fights
whenever it comes down to uh the
confidence in the accuracy of memory
i just say no we both have to admit that
we're both wrong and let's let's try and
work out
about this let's turn the fight to where
to something current
because that's a that's an irresolvable
issue
but but but but we we have to you know
so even and even in that quote the
pretense of the stability of narrative
is that it's not
true the postmoderns they can't live
without the moderns
i mean it's simply the way that the
pattern lays out as jonathan would say
well and i'm not pushing against it i
think it's right and i think
the the quest now as we're getting as
modernity is receding
is to not lose do not lose the benefits
of what we
earned in modernity in the phase that
comes
next in our instantiation of those
phases
because that's i think what what
happened in the movement from
from christendom into modernity
and even and you know even in the
movement from
the pagan into the christian era
and so as we travel we try to
say okay we'll we'll we'll we'll concede
that
we got a discrepancy on the date here
but let's also understand the value
of of of what is clearly valuable
uh to us now and these things are hard
to all
be and i think the the culmination of
the
eminent the emergent and the eminent
coming together is
in fact the the fruition of
all things that's what we're looking for
even in
our project i agree
i think that's good so there's something
that's occurring to me that
so it sounded to me um
because what you said about trying to
keep the two and it sounded to me what
jonathan was saying is
like that's why i use the word
anticipation because it's not quite the
same thing as prediction prediction is
third person
uh anticipation is transjective it
integrates the third person and the
first person together
right i can predict the end of the
universe but saying that i anticipate it
makes no sense
right but i anticipate you know uh going
to work later in the day or something
like that
so because it's what i'm saying is it
it's not just propositional
it's procedural it's perspectival and
participatory and then what i heard
jonathan saying is
you know that there are con and i agree
with this there are kinds of predictions
and they're also postdictions
right because you're also not you're not
just
you're not just anticipating future
patterns and pretend
right you're also picking up on
perennial patterns is that fair
and that's what i mean by post-diction
or maybe always diction rather than
prediction and post-diction
maybe that will coin a new phrase always
diction
but that's a good word for all of
jonathan's work
so what i heard jonathan saying is that
you know if you'll allow me and you know
you both know that i use this word in a
non-pejorative fashion
that there's something like mythic
anticipation or mythic always diction
that's important and valuable and then
what what i'm trying to get out with
what you just said
paul is yeah but you know what's also
really good at we're really really good
at prediction is
it is the scientific world view it's
really good at detecting patterns
and remember science isn't what it state
what
the content of science is constantly
changing this is a mistake this is
i think this is the fundamental mistake
of scientism scientism is to equate
science with
its current products science is a
process of overcoming self-deception
in in the ways we try and detect
patterns
and you know it's really powerful for
distinguishing causal and correlational
patterns
constitutive patterns from causal
patterns etc that's very very powerful
and so i i'm looking for a way
of trying to get these two to talk
together because if what we're at
ultimately about is pattern detection
then the the the
i'll use your term now the narrative we
need is the one
that has to encompass this tremendous
process
again do not equate science with its
current claims
that's a ridiculous thing to do that's
like equating you
with what you say right now in this
moment that's a mistake
that's the mistake of scientism i
acknowledge it i
reject that mistake science is a family
of processes
for overcoming self-deception in order
to enhance
pattern detection and if that's what
we're talking about here
science has to be included and it can't
be included
at like as like you know sort of the the
the the somewhat
you know the somewhat daft second cousin
or something like that it has to have an
important seat at the table
that's what i'm arguing for here no i i
think you really pushed
you pushed a button in my own little
polemic uh attitude which is that
because science has been treating
me like the daft cousin for a few
centuries i want to turn around and slap
it around a little bit
you know so that it stops being so
arrogant but i agree that ultimately
you're right and i think that and i
think that that's why i'm
excited about this this these new
horizons coming out of cognitive science
because i feel like the
the return to consciousness or the
understanding of
the effect of consciousness and the
relationship between unconsciousness and
meaning making
and how that in a way fills up
kind of fills up the horizon of of our
understanding
where we realize the inevitability of
understanding consciousness if we want
to go further in
understanding the way the world lays
itself out then
i think that it's there that we're going
to see the biggest
connections between the two sides or the
mythic
side and the the more technical side you
know because
you're right in terms of mythical when
you talk about mythical prediction
that's what revelation is revelation is
is mythical prediction it uses all the
patterns of the old testament
it's there's nothing in revelations
almost nothing in revelation
which is not in like in the book of
revelation ezekiel or yeah in the book
of revelation
there's nothing that's not there in all
the other books in scripture it's
it's actually it's taking these these uh
prophetic
patterns of seeing the rel the the
pattern of reality
using imagistic language and is now
telling you
putting it into a predictive mode where
it's saying this is this is what you
have to expect in terms of
patterns as the world kind of as the
story plays itself out and so
because a lot of people don't see it
that way it's one of the reasons why
they don't understand it because they
they always want to they're always
wanting to just identify
like who's that figure like who's what
historical figure corresponds to that
figure in in revelation i think that
that's
that's missing the missing the point in
terms of pattern
uh making but anyways i'm kind of off
off the track here but
i totally think that you're right and
the image of the
of the and i'm gonna put my last little
the the image of the last age in in
scripture the final image is
the is the city it's not i always tell
you i always remind people it's not
uh it's not the garden anymore or the
garden is surrounded by the city
and the city is exactly that image of a
technical understanding or technical
realization and so it has to it becomes
a form of glory
in the end although it was in the
narrative of scripture a result of the
fall
and they kind of uh it kind of imagined
like a
desire to show your cane right yeah
exactly to protect yourself to cover
yourself
to create these buffers so that you so
that you're protected from the outside
world
it ultimately ends up being a kind of
glory in the
in the last moment you could say
jonathan you really do have a genius for
symbolic
thought like like you draw things out
that i've never seen before
um i just want to compliment you on that
it's a sincere compliment
uh it's like it's it's it's impressive
there's an artistry to it that
i just i i respect i think it's really
powerful
i and i would i would just tweak the
book of revelation a bit
because i think the book of revelation
is is old testament
prophecy plus the revelation of jesus
christ because that's
actually the new element between ezekiel
daniel
um and the children of cain as it as it
as it arrives there in the the new
jerusalem
but you know i no i i think that's
no this was this is this has been
excellent and maybe we should
maybe we should land we probably should
be going for two hours i rarely
able to go for two hours i think we
should maybe close it off here
i feel one of my one of my criteria one
of
the one my mark of the logos is with
the where their participants get to a
place um that they couldn't get to on
their own but they
everybody feels that they got to a place
collectively that they couldn't get to
on their own and that's
you know and i don't mean this
sacrilegiously you know jesus where two
or three are gathered in my name
and there i am also the you know that
that something more than
just the three of us something emerged
um but the emergence also disclosed the
overarching sacred canopy
of emanation uh for me at least in this
and so i wanted to thank you both for
this
i thought it was great yeah i thank you
i really really appreciate it too i
think you
i think one of the things that i noticed
is that every time i talk to both of you
i end up on paths that i've never been
and
and i say things that i've never said
and i realized and i wonder like why do
i have never said that before as i'm
saying
and so it's actually for me it's like a
wonderful trip to be like oh yeah this
is like
pulling things out of my mind that i
that i that i
had never said and so it's it's it's
always a good it's always a wonderful
trip to be one with you guys so i
appreciate it i agree with everything
that's been said
so thank you both and i will i will send
this i will
once this is rendered i will send it to
both of you yeah we could we could just
all post it on our channel that i think
that would be fun like oh yeah
we'll post it all i'll post it on my
channel today and jonathan
you can do whatever you watch and uh i i
would i'll
i'm not to obligate anybody but i think
this was valuable
and i would like to do it again at some
point yeah
definitely all right take care gentlemen
all right bye everybody
bye